THE OPPOSITE IS TRUE.
WE WILL ALSO TALK ABOUT
JOE BIDEN AND KAMALA HARRIS AND
THEY ARE NOW READY TO BE
ANOINTED FROM THEIR BASEMENT
BUNKERS.
THEY CAN’T HIDE, THEY’RE GOING
TO CAMPAIGN.
NO THEY’RE NOT.
APPARENTLY, THEY’RE GOING TO
MEET WITH THE VOTERS, CERTAINLY
AREN’T GOING TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THEIR ADORING
CULT FANS OF PROPAGANDA.
THAT WOULD BE THE MOB AND THE
MEDIA.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> LET’S GO.
LET’S GO, COME ON.
LET’S GO, YOU GUYS, COME ON.
LET’S GO.
COME ON, LET’S GO.
YOU GUYS, LET’S GO.
>> SENIOR WASHINGTON
CORRESPONDENT JOINING ME NOW, A
COUPLE NOTES, JEFF.
NOT A WHOLE LOT OF QUESTIONS
FROM REPORTERS THERE.
WE KEEP PRESSING THE BIDEN
CAMPAIGN, THERE NEEDS TO BE MORE
QUESTIONS FROM REPORTERS, WE
KNOW THAT.
IF YOU >> Sean: MAY BE TWO
PRESSERS WITH IN THE
TELEPROMPTER, I’M SUPPOSED TO GO
TO JOE NOW.
IN 140 DAYS, TWO, REALLY.
ARE THEY GOING TO DEBATE OR ARE
THEY GOING TO TRY TO DUCK THAT,
TOO?
THE MOB AND THE MEDIA ARE
ALREADY FAWNING OVER KAMALA
HARRIS, THEY LOVE JOE, NEW YORK
TOILET PAPER TIMES CALLS FOR A
PRAGMATIC MODERATE.
THAT IS ANOTHER LIE BY THE
NEW YORK TOILET PAPER TIMES.
GEORGE STEPHANOPOULOS,
MAKE-BELIEVE JOURNALISTS OVER AT
FAKE NEWS ABC SPREADING THE SAME
B.S., TAKE A LOOK.
>> KAMALA COMMENTS FROM THE
MIDDLE IT RODE MODERATE WEIGHING
OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY, NOT THE
FIRST CHOICE OF PROGRESSIVES BUT
JOE BIDEN MAKING THIS HISTORIC
MOVE AS THE FIRST WOMAN OF COLOR
ON A NATIONAL TICKET WILL
OVERCOME THAT.
>> Sean: THAT’S NOT TRUE,
EITHER.
THE MOB AND THE MEDIA 99% STATE
RUN DEMOCRATIC SOCIALIST FAKE
NEWS BUT YEAH, TOTALLY MODERATE.
EXCEPT FOR HER REAL VOTING
RECORD, 2019, FOR EXAMPLE.
JEEZ TO THE LEFT OF BOLSHEVIK
BERNIE SANDERS.
AND HER SUPPORT OF, OH, YEAH,
MEDICARE FOR ALL WITH ZERO
CHANCE OF YOU HAVING YOUR OWN
HEALTH CARE PROVIDER.
NO CHOICE.
I THOUGHT LIBERALS WERE
PRO-JOYCE AND HER SPONSORSHIP OF
THE NEW GREEN DEAL.
IT’S COSPONSOR IN U.S. SENATE.
PENNSYLVANIA, OHIO, MICHIGAN,
ARE YOU WATCHING THIS?
LIMIT BY THE WAY, THAT’S ALL
MODERATE, SURE.
I SEE GEORGIE HASN’T CHANGED
SINCE HIS DAYS TRYING TO BULLY
REPORTERS INTO NOT PUBLISHING
STORIES ABOUT BILL CLINTON’S
AFFAIRS.
GEORGE STEPHANOPOULOS, NOTHING
BUT A FAR LEFT POLITICAL HACK
MASQUERADING AS A JOURNALIST.
ABC NEWS, WELL, THEY ARE NOT
TELLING YOU THE TRUTH AND THEY
ARE NOT ALONE.
NATURALLY SOME OF KAMALA HARRIS’
BIGGEST CHEERLEADERS WORK FOR
FAKE NEWS CNN AND THEY ARE FAKE.
HERE’S WHAT THEIR VETTING
PROCESS LOOKS LIKE OVER THERE,
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I THINK SHE GAVE A VERY
POWERFUL SPEECH AND IF THERE’S
ANY DOUBT THAT KAMALA HARRIS IS
NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO GO ON
THE ATTACK AS VICE PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATE USUALLY DO, THAT WAS
ERASED TODAY.
>> KAMALA HARRIS GAVE A
FANTASTIC SPEECH, ABSOLUTELY
NAILED IT.
HER ABILITY I THINK SHOWS THIS
TREMENDOUS RANGE, THE PERSONAL
SIDE OF HER.
>> LOOK, IT WAS A BEAUTIFUL
SPEECH.
BOTH OF THEM, THEY STRENGTHEN
EACH OTHER.
IF YOU’VE GOT TO GIVE A HEADLINE
TODAY IT WOULD BE "HOPE REBORN."
>> AS OPPOSED TO JUST A
HIGH SCHOOL GYMNASIUM THERE AND
I THINK THAT THE EASE IN WHICH
THEY WORK TOGETHER WAS VERY
APPARENT.
>> Sean: THAT’S THE EXACT
OPPOSITE WHEN SHE GOT LESS THAN
2% OF THE PRIMARY AND SHE DID
MEMORIZE HER ATTACK LINES WELL
AND DELIVERED THEM AND CALLED
JOE BIDEN PRETTY MUCH A RACIST.
SO YOU’VE GOT JOE BIDEN, KAMALA
HARRIS RUNNING FOR THE HIGHEST
OFFICE IN THE LAND.
YEAH, THERE WOULD BE CRITICAL
QUESTIONS BUT THE MOB NEEDS TO
ASK JOE AND KAMALA, THEY’VE GOT
TO ANSWER.
TODAY, BIDEN ANNOUNCED A PLAN
IMPOSE A FEDERAL MASK MANDATE.
HE WANTS EVERY AMERICAN TO WEAR
A MASK ANY TIME HE STEPS OUTSIDE
OF YOUR HOME.
I’VE BEEN VERY OUTSPOKEN, I’M
ALL FORM AMERICANS VOLUNTARILY
WEARING MASKS WHEN IT’S CROWDED
AND YOU CAN’T SOCIALLY DISTANCE.
I SAID ANECDOTALLY, AT THE SUPER
SUPERMARKET AND THE EPICENTER OF
THE MIDST OF THE WORST MOMENTS
IN NEW YORK, THEY HAD MASKS AND
PLASTIC, ANECDOTALLY, THEY WORK
AND GUESS WHAT?
WE’RE GOING TO HAVE MASK BULLIES
NEXT?
NEXT THEY SAY AFTER OPERATION
WARP SPEED OF PRESIDENT TRUMP
AND NOW IN FINAL STAGE TRIALS
FOR A VACCINE, WE’RE GOING TO
MANDATE THAT?
I WOULD SAY THAT’S UP TO PEOPLE
TO DECIDE.
THEY GET TO CHOOSE.
WILL THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION BE
HANDING OUT FINES OR ARRESTING
PEOPLE THAT DON’T COMPLY WITH
THEIR MANDATE?
ARE THEY UNIVERSAL?
WHAT ABOUT JOGGING OUTDOORS?
SWIMMING IN THE OCEAN OR ON A
BEACH, WHAT ABOUT THOSE WHO WORK
OUTDOORS?
PROFESSIONAL SPORTS ATHLETES,
DOES THE FIRST BASEMENT HAVE TO
SOCIALLY DISTANT FROM THIS BUT
SECOND BASEMAN AND THE SHORTSTOP
OR THIRD BASEMAN?
WHAT ABOUT PEOPLE EATING IN A
RESTAURANT OR EATING OUTDOORS?
OR ANY OF THESE QUESTIONS EVER
GOING TO BE ANSWERED?
THIS IS JUST ONE ISSUE THAT MUST
BE ADDRESSED.
DURING THE PRIMARIES,
SENATOR HARRIS RAISING NUMEROUS
SERIOUS CONCERNS.
I THINK SHE MEMORIZED HER LINES
AND DELIVERED THEM QUITE WELL
WHEN SHE CONFRONTED, WELL, THE
EVER-FORGETFUL CORRUPT JOE ABOUT
HIS WORK WITH SEGREGATION AND
OPPOSING IMMIGRATION AND SO MUCH
MORE.
WE WILL REMIND YOU.
>> ON THE HYDE AMENDMENT WHERE
YOU MADE A DECISION FOR YEARS TO
WITHHOLD RESOURCES TO POOR WOMEN
TO HAVE ACCESS TO REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE AND INCLUDING WOMEN
WHO WERE THE VICTIMS OF RAPE AND
INCEST, DO YOU NOW SAY YOU HAVE
EVOLVED AND YOU REGRET THAT?
ONLY SINCE YOU’VE BEEN RUNNING
FOR PRESIDENT THIS TIME.
>> I BELIEVE THEM AND I RESPECT
THEM BEING ABLE TO TELL THEIR
STORY AND HAVING THE COURAGE TO
DO IT.
>> DO YOU BELIEVE THAT THE
VICE PRESIDENT SHOULD ENTER THIS
RACE?
>> HE IS GOING TO HAVE TO MAKE
THAT DECISION FOR HIMSELF.
>> THE ISSUE OF LYNCHING IS PART
OF THE STAIN ON AMERICA’S
HISTORY.
>> HE APOLOGIZED THIS MORNING ON
TWITTER SAYING "I SHOULD NOT
HAVE USE THOSE WORDS."
DO YOU ACCEPT THAT APOLOGY?
>> I THINK IT’S RIGHT FOR HIM TO
APOLOGIZE, YEAH.
YOU ALSO WORK WITH THEM TO
OPPOSE BUSING AND THERE WAS A
LITTLE GIRL IN CALIFORNIA WHO
WAS PART OF THE SECOND CLASS TO
INTEGRATE HER PUBLIC SCHOOL AND
SHE WAS BUSED TO SCHOOL EVERY
DAY AND THAT LITTLE GIRL WAS ME.
>> Sean: WOW.
KAMALA HAS EVOLVED.
ELECTION-YEAR CONVERSION I GUESS
YOU MIGHT SAY.
ALSO, KAMALA HARRIS ALSO
BELIEVED JOE BIDEN’S ACCUSERS.
SHE SYMPATHIZED WITH ALL THE
WOMEN, JOE MADE REALLY
UNCOMFORTABLE WITH THIS CREEPY
GROPING AND TOUCHING AND
HUGGING, REMEMBER ALL OF THIS?
♪ ♪
>> I GOT HARRY LEGS, THAT TURNED
BLONDE IN THE SUN.
♪ ♪
AND THE KIDS USED TO COME UP AND
REACH IN AND PULL AND WATCH THE
HAIR COME BACK UP AGAIN.
♪ ♪
>> Sean: WE ARE NOT EVEN
SHOWING YOU THE REALLY CREEPY
MOMENTS WITH YOUNGER PEOPLE.
KAMALA, DID YOU FORGET ABOUT
THAT?
DO YOU KNOW LONGER CARE ABOUT
THIS?
DID YOU HAVE ALL COME AS YOU
SAY, MAYBE JUST USE THE WORDS,
YEAH.
EVOLVING.
WHAT ABOUT BIDEN’S WORK WITH
SEGREGATIONISTS TO SLOW SCHOOL
INTEGRATION?
HE WORKED WITH THE GUY WHO
ACTUALLY FILIBUSTERED THE
HISTORIC CIVIL RIGHTS ACT AND
DIDN’T SUPPORT THE VOTING CIVIL
RIGHTS ACT AND YOUR BFF
PARTNERED WITH THE FORMER
KLANSMAN BECAUSE JOE BIDEN
DIDN’T WANT HIS CHILDREN TO GROW
UP IN A RACIAL JUNGLE IF HIS
KIDS WENT TO INTEGRATED SCHOOLS.
DO YOU JUST NO LONGER CARE THAT
BIDEN WAS CLOSE TO THE FORMER
KLANSMAN, PRAISE TO THE FORMER
KLANSMAN, WORKED WITH THE FORMER
KLANSMAN ON SOMETHING LIKE
INTEGRATION?
YOU TALK ABOUT THAT IN THE
DEBATE MOMENT YOU HAD, WHAT
ABOUT PRINCIPAL?
WHAT ABOUT HIS COMMENT, YOU
CAN’T GO TO A 7-ELEVEN OR
DUNKIN’ DONUTS UNLESS YOU HAVE A
SLIGHT INDIAN ACCENT?
WHAT ABOUT HIS RECENT COMMENTS
SUGGESTING THAT
AFRICAN-AMERICANS ARE ALL THE
SAME OR POOR KIDS ARE JUST AS
SMART AS WHITE KIDS?
OKAY, REALLY?
THE MOB AND THE MEDIA, GOING TO
ASK THESE QUESTIONS, ARE YOU
THAT DESPERATE IN THIS CASE TO
BE VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES?
WE WILL JUST FORGET ABOUT ALL OF
THIS.
OF COURSE THIS ISN’T JUST ABOUT
SENATOR HARRIS, IT’S ABOUT
EVERYONE IN THE MOB AND THE
MEDIA, THEY REFUSE TO VET
JOE BIDEN.
WE WILL DO THEIR JOB AS THEY
ALWAYS DO.
THE PRESIDENT ANSWERED DOZENS OF
QUESTIONS LIKE HE ALMOST IS ON A
DAILY BASIS FROM A HOSTILE PRESS
CORPS, A CULT THAT IS PSYCHOTIC
IN THEIR HATRED OF HIM.
WHY DOESN’T JOE BIDEN, WHY
DOESN’T KAMALA HARRIS ANSWER
QUESTIONS?
WHERE IS THEIR LENGTHY PRESS
CONFERENCE?
MY GUESS IS THEY ARE GOING TO
SHOW UP FOR A FLUFFY INTERVIEW
ON FAKE NEWS CNN, SHOW UP ON
CONSPIRACY TV, THAT’S WHEN THEY
WILL SHOW UP, PROBABLY NOWHERE
ELSE.
ARE THEY GOING TO SHOW UP FOR
THE DEBATES?
ARE THEY NOT CAPABLE OF THE
TOUGH QUESTIONS?
CHRIS WALLACE, GO ON WITH
ANYBODY.
THAT WILL ASK YOU TOUGH
QUESTIONS.
WHAT ARE THEY HIDING?
IS IT THAT THEY ARE RADICAL OUT
OF TOUCH TO SOCIALISTS, IS IT
JOE BIDEN’S RACIST RHETORIC?
IS IT JOE BIDEN, AN OBVIOUS LACK
OF STRENGTH AND STAMINA AND
MENTAL ACUITY, MENTAL ALERTNESS.
BECAUSE I THINK THE ANSWER MAY
BE ALL OF THE ABOVE AND IN 82
DAYS THE AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE TO